Film is an expensive and complicated medium.
When storytellers suddenly realize that their
movie is heading for an unsatisfying conclusion,
it can result in some exhausting and expensive
behind-the-scenes headaches for everyone involved.
Thankfully, these beloved movies swapped out
their iffy endings just in time… for the
most part.
At the beginning of Scott Pilgrim vs. the
World, the eponymous hero is caught between
two women: his "too young for him" girlfriend
Knives Chau and the mysterious Ramona Flowers.
Early on in the film, he cheats on Knives
with Ramona, and then breaks up with Knives
altogether, but his new relationship with
Ramona is far from smooth.
"If we're gonna date, you may have to defeat
my seven evil exes."
"You have seven evil ex-boyfriends?"
"Seven evil exes, yes."
How does the story end?
Well, when Edgar Wright and Michael Bacall
were writing the script for Scott Pilgrim
vs the World, they had a unique problem.
It was based on a six-part comic series by
Bryan Lee O'Malley, but only five of the six
books had been released at the time.
There was no ending for them to adapt.
The initial ending they penned had Scott realizing
that Ramona wasn't right for him, and so he
and Knives got back together.
This ending was shot and appears as a bonus
feature on the Blu-Ray.
"Well, bye and stuff."
"Yeah.
And stuff."
But something about it didn't feel right during
filming.
In addition to test audiences not liking it,
one of the loudest voices against it was Ellen
Wong, the actor playing Knives, who didn't
want her character going back to a man who
cheated on her.
In the final ending, despite their problems,
Scott and Ramona decide that they're going
to try to make it work, and Knives learns
to stand on her own.
"Bye and stuff."
"Yeah.
And stuff."
"Go get her."
This ended up matching the resolution of the
comic series, the last volume of which was
released less than a month before the film
hit theaters.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story was a project
that was constantly shifting around during
all stages of its production.
There was an early version of the script where
protagonist Jyn Erso was a Sergeant an enlisted
soldier in the Rebel Alliance instead of a
criminal who was pressured into joining the
rebellion.
In some versions of the script, she and Cassian
actually survived the battle on Scarif.
This incarnation of Jyn was the one that the
filmmakers thought they would be going with
when much of the merchandise was created.
Because of that, some of the packaging for
the toys still refers to Jyn as Sergeant Jyn
Erso.
However, there was another key change to the
ending that was made very late into the filming
process.
While looking over the footage they had filmed
for the climax, director Gareth Edwards and
editor Jabez Olssen realized that Darth Vader,
despite being introduced in an early scene,
never really got a chance to do anything cool
in the third act.
They decided he needed an action scene of
his own, and so the now-iconic Darth Vader
hallway fight scene was shot just four months
before the film was released.
As a filmmaker, Terry Gilliam is known for
two things: making amazing, surreal movies
and having terrible luck while trying to make
amazing, surreal movies.
The story of his 1985 film Brazil showcases
both of these traits.
Brazil tells the story of Sam Lowry, who lives
in a totalitarian futuristic bureaucracy but
dreams of being a winged hero who fights monsters
and rescues damsels.
After a series of misadventures, Sam is captured
by the authorities for associating with criminal
revolutionaries.
In the original ending, he seemingly breaks
out of captivity and flees the city to an
idyllic countryside.
But then, there is a sudden reveal that he
hasn't fled at all.
He is still in prison, merely dreaming of
escape after being lobotomized.
The Criterion documentary The Battle of Brazil
tells the story of what happened next.
Distributors felt that U.S. audiences would
want a happier ending.
"I would get calls from the editor occasionally
wanting my input.
What do you mean, you want my input?
'You know, but we're saving your film.'
No, no, no — you're killing my film."
Against Gilliam's wishes, an editing team
created an alternate cut that ended with Sam
actually escaping, forgoing the reveal that
it was just a hallucination.
This was the version of Brazil that originally
premiered in the United States.
Fortunately, this is not the end of the story.
Gilliam, unhappy with this result, starting
hosting private screenings of his version
of the film.
His cut started getting positive critical
attention, eventually winning the Los Angeles
Film Critics Award for Best Picture.
This made the studio finally cave and release
the original version to American audiences.
When Sean Harris was cast in Mission: Impossible
- Rogue Nation as the villainous Solomon Lane,
he had only one request, without which he
would not agree to do the film.
He said, quote, "Promise me you'll kill him…
I don't want to be in five of these movies."
Writer/director Christopher McQuarrie agreed.
By the end of the film, protagonist Ethan
Hunt would kill Solomon Lane.
The problem?
Late into process of filming, McQuarrie made
an upsetting discovery.
IndieWire reports that the writer/director
admitted, quote, "I [didn't] have the event
in the movie that [made] me want Ethan to
kill him."
In fact, McQuarrie felt it would be more satisfying
if Ethan tricked Lane, defeating him without
violence, and brought him into custody alive.
After some pleading, McQuarrie eventually
got Harris to agree to a script change.
In the end, Harris, like his character, was
trapped.
It hasn't been five films yet, but Solomon
Lane did indeed have to return in Mission:
Impossible - Fallout.
Pretty in Pink tells the story of Andie Walsh
played by Molly Ringwald a highschooler caught
between two love interests: the preppy hunk
Blaine and Duckie, the boy next door.
Originally, the plan was for Andie to learn
that people who are rich and attractive like
Blaine can sometimes be shallow, and people
who don't look like much are often the real
treasure.
That's, of course, Duckie we're talking about.
However, once filming began, Ringwald and
McCarthy ended up having undeniable chemistry.
Duckie, meanwhile, came off as a deeply weird
dude with strange fashion sense, odd mannerisms,
and an almost stalker-esque obsession with
Andie.
The film was shot as originally written, with
Andie ending up with Duckie, but audiences
who were shown early cuts of the film just
about lost their minds.
As director Howard Deutch put it:
"The girls in the test screening didn't go
for that… they wanted her to get the cute
boy.
And that was it.
So we had to reshoot the ending."
The final version of the film did indeed have
Andie ending up with Blaine, but the change
happened so late into the process that the
novelization of the film still has the original
ending.
This change never sat well with writer John
Hughes.
Wanting another chance to properly execute
this story, he wrote Some Kind of Wonderful,
which has a very similar setup to Pretty in
Pink, but this time ends with the lead choosing
the normie over the hottie.
Realism be damned!
World War Z's original ending, which was actually
filmed, was an enormous and expensive action
set piece, with protagonist Gerry Lane played
by Brad Pitt fighting his way through hundreds
of zombies in Moscow's Red Square.
However, when watching it back, the filmmakers
felt that it just wasn't working.
The story began with a strong focus on Gerry's
desire to reunite with his family, but it
ended with a meaningless bloodbath and no
resolution to his main goal.
In an interview with Vanity Fair, second unit
director Simon Crane said that the biggest
problem was that, quote, "it wasn't character-driven
anymore."
Writer Damon Lindelof was brought on to take
things back to the drawing board and do something
that had never been done before on a film
of this scale: write a completely new final
40 minutes to an already finished film.
In the version that hit theaters, the new
climax is confined to an abandoned hospital.
The action is small, with Gerry as a frightened
everyman, rather than a swaggering badass.
Most importantly, in the end, he's finally
reunited with his family.
Even though Ridley Scott's Blade Runner is
considered a classic nowadays, it was not
always a favorite of sci fi cinephiles.
When it premiered, reviews were lukewarm,
and some last minute studio meddling may have
been to blame.
In Scott's initial cut, the storytelling was
gloomy and mysterious, especially the last
shot of the film, which showed our protagonists
on the run from the law, boarding an elevator
to an uncertain fate.
According to the making-of documentary On
the Edge of Blade Runner, initial test screenings
indicated that this highly ambiguous plot
did its job a little too well, because everyone
who saw it felt highly confused.
"What the f--- am I watching here?"
The studio pressured Scott to add not only
a voiceover narration to make things clearer,
but also a new ending that showed the heroes
driving through the sunny countryside, indicating
that they'd found some semblance of happiness.
The production was out of money, but Scott
was suddenly in need of some idyllic landscape
footage.
He turned to his friend, Stanley Kubrick,
who happened to have 17 hours of beautiful
unused b-roll that he originally shot for
the opening titles of The Shining.
Despite everyone's best efforts, the fix ended
up pleasing exactly nobody.
Some still thought the movie was confusing,
while others thought the new voiceover and
ending were too corny.
It wasn't until 1992 that Ridley Scott released
a version of the film more in line with his
initial vision, and lovers of confusing gloom
finally got the flick they'd been dreaming
of.
Speaking of Stanley Kubrick, the notoriously
intense director is no stranger to switching
things up at the last possible minute.
How "last minute" are we talking, exactly?
Well, he changed the ending to The Shining
a week after it came out!
The initial ending of the film featured an
additional scene between the two now-famous
final beats of Jack freezing to death in the
hedge maze and the closing shot of that spooky
group photo back in the Overlook.
This diversion showed Wendy and Danny recovering
in a hospital and talking to the police about
what they experienced.
This scene was actually shown at the premiere
and in the film's initial limited run in Los
Angeles and New York.
Then, before the wider release of the film,
Kubrick decided the scene was superfluous
and sent out assistants to actually travel
around to dozens of theaters and physically
cut out the scene, re-editing the film reels
that the theaters had been showing.
The scene is not currently available anywhere,
since all copies of it were theoretically
destroyed.
Only a few set photos still exist, but the
evidence of how late this change occurred
can be seen in that two characters from that
scene, a "Policeman" and a "Nurse," still
appear in the final credits, despite no longer
being in the movie.
So, in summation: Blade Runner's team took
footage from The Shining to create a new ending,
while The Shining crew also crafted a new
ending for the horror film by racing around
the country and taking razor blades to films,
effectively becoming — pardon the pun — "blade
runners."
"Oh!
I get it."
The classic '90s slacker comedy Clerks tells
the story of a day in the life of sad sack
convenience store clerk Dante Hicks.
Even though the film garnered critical acclaim,
jump-started the career of director Kevin
Smith, and introduced the world to Jay and
Silent Bob, the original ending told a drastically
different story.
In its first public screening at the Independent
Feature Film Market, Clerks ended with one
last customer entering the store as Dante
was closing up for the night.
He was an armed robber who, without warning
or fanfare, shot Dante dead, emptied the register,
and walked away.
Talk about a dead end job!
In the making-of documentary Snowball Effect:
The Story of Clerks, Smith admits that he
did this because he didn't know how else to
close the film, and because he was copying
the structure of Spike Lee's Do the Right
Thing, which also takes place entirely in
one day and ends in tragedy.
Brian O'Halloran, the actor who played Dante,
hated this ending, as did Smith's mentor,
filmmaker John Pierson.
Pierson suggested simply cutting that scene
and ending on the happy note that preceded
it.
That's exactly what Smith did, and so all
future screenings ended in a way that better
fit the tone of the rest of the film, and
left the door open for a sequel.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.